you have the growth Target now
um can you tell us what was the last UK
government to have a great Target well
there have been various targets of
various governments over the years this
would be an economic growth time because
there was only one just recently yes it
was list Crossing quasi-course had a
growth Target so is that a strange
precedent to follow no I've never
quarreled with the argument that what we
need is growth but you've got
um a direct comparison there you've got
a kamikasi approach that disregards all
of the institutions has not got a stable
strategic plan behind it with Liz trust
uh Liz truss and had the obvious
consequence of doing huge damage to our
economy all the labor alternative which
is a fully thought through strategic
plan that will be implemented in
partnership with business and you've
seen I think today the appetite there is
for businesses they want certainty
that's the complete opposite of what
they've got from US government have you
seen you know what would happen if you
did actually achieve that growth Target
because it's quite ambitious to be the
highest GDP per capita in the G7 if you
actually achieved that what kind of a
place would this be what would the
numbers look like in you know 10 years
time well what I want to see is raise
living standards across the country so
in many places the discussion in the
local pub or Cafe will not be about the
Strategic plan for growth but it will be
about my living standards how well off
am I am I able to do those extra things
I want to do with my family am I seeing
it reflected in my High Street can I see
my public services working better for me
my family and my community so that's why
I've said our model of growth has to be
growth everywhere but it has to be laser
focused on living standards which I
think across the country most people say
I desperately need my living standards
raised and you'll say it's a living
standards GDP per capita so yes and then
where does the UK kind of stand with
other countries potentially well uh GDP
per capita is one of the factors or
growth measures that we're going to put
into place but there are others
including
um you know living standards across the
country so it's very important that this
is a plan for growth which is across the
whole of the United Kingdom brings
everybody with it and all individuals
and families can see the effect it's
having on them at the end of the month
when they've got more money they're able
to do more things they want to do and
take our country forward I just ask
because if you know if you did hit that
and if we had the highest rate of growth
in the G7 you know yeah over the recent
years we would still be overtaken by
Poland in 2037. so even this very
ambitious Target doesn't necessarily
look good in respect to that statistic
that you're talking about quite a lot
today what I
um said that's very strongly from many
many businesses and chief Executives
both of companies here in the UK and
globally is that there's a huge appetite
to invest what they say to me is the
inhibitor of that is the lack of
stability you know we've been through
but through what three prime ministers
and four chancellors in 12 months that
doesn't create the conditions for
stability so I want growth that is
strategic that is long-term and where
our ambition is to be to have the
highest sustained growth in the G7 and I
know I'm gonna apologize for that
ambition because it translates into
higher living standards for millions of
people across the country